George the next category is for best
foreign film now I don't want to seem
unworldly or unsophisticated or anything
but this is the American Academy right
why is it important for us to give an
award to the best foreign film well
think of it this way we remember what
foreign films have done for us in the
last 20 years alone
they've given us directors like Ingmar
Bergman De Sica Fellini antonioni
lelouch Kurosawa Truffaut Renoir they're
cooler Bertolucci they're given a stars
like Loren Mastriani Gusman Bardo Yves
Martin leave omen Toshiro Mifune
they've given us innovations technique
iconoclastic cinematic form bold and
graphic incursions into the deepest
depths of the human soul and you know
what else they've done goli they've
taken the bread right out of our mouths
to preserve whoops let me the award for
best boy oh one of the most attractive
and gifted players on the international
screen today a bilingual lady whom I
just loved in Murder on the Orient
Express and Francois Truffaut's day for
night Jacqueline Bisset and with her
with her and what has become a
distinguished tradition a gentleman
whose remarks will certainly be rated G
the president of the Motion Picture
Association of America Jack Valenti
question Jackie what's the most wanted
export of the United States well
considering it here is nod waitress the
American movie and you'd win in more
than 120 countries the American film is
this nation's most popular ambassador
and next to the president who is the
American most recognizable on any Street
anywhere in the world and the answer is
the American movie star Cody and George
pointed out that the American movie star
is frequently British French Swedish or
Greek accessory etc well of course and
that's because talent knows no
nationality it's no accident then that
the films we honor tonight or Russian
polish Mexican Japanese and Italian
which reaffirms eloquently that the
magic of the screen is international and
boundless and now to those splendid
films of unusual excellence the nominees
for Best Foreign Language Film are from
the USSR dersu uzala from Poland the
land of promise from Mexico letters from
Marusya and from Japan SantaCon number
eight ultimately Scent of a Woman and
the winner is USSR for DES ooh-la-la
you argued the middle
from Japan
ladies and gentlemen in the event that
mr. Kurosawa was honored by the Academy
tonight he has asked me in his behalf to
read a statement for him a statement
that he has written and this is what he
says may I take this opportunity to say
a word to filmmakers throughout the
world in no other time in cinematic
history has there been as much need as
there is today for young power in the
production of motion pictures I will
continue making films until my very last
day so young filmmakers throughout the
world please follow me and let us join
hands and make good films together
signed Akira Kurosawa
I'm very touched
well these Oscars very beautiful and a
wonderful present for all our staffs and
the artists who have been working in a
good collaboration for two years thank
you very much
I don't speak English but thank you very
much
you